[Music]
today would have been princess diana's
60th birthday her children prince
william and prince harry are in london
this morning
to unveil a statue in her honor putting
their troubled relationship
it seems aside for now mts taeb is at
kensington palace where the statue
stands outside diana's former home
mts this is a big day good morning to
you
well yeah there's obviously a huge
amount of anticipation here in just a
few hours we're going to see the
unveiling
of the diana statue at her former home
kensington palace
but of course all eyes will be on her
two sons princess william and harry
in life princess diana broke the mold
for what it meant to be a modern royal
a legacy that still endures 24 years
after her death following harry and wife
megan's decision to step back from royal
duties last year
and publicly criticized the royal family
in a candid interview with oprah
harry's growing rift with his brother
prince william was laid bare
and threatens to overshadow any tributes
to their late mother
robert lacy is the author of battle of
brothers
it is love against duty in terms of the
the issues involved it's
william defending the monarchy and uh
harry defending his wife
diana's deep commitment to humanitarian
work was amplified not only by her
dazzling presence but with her ability
to connect with people
when she died at the age of 36 the
outpouring of grief for the people's
princess
was unlike anything the monarchy had
seen before
and the images of her two sons then just
12 and 15 years old
broke hearts with every step they made
on the long walk behind their mother's
casket
it would be at another funeral for their
grandfather prince philip in
april which saw the brothers briefly
reunited since their differences came to
light
side by side once again
but reportedly still not in step with
one another
as william harry and the world reflect
on what would have been princess diana's
60th birthday
her legacy not only endures but
continues to shape the royal family
says robert lacy this unveiling of a
statue to diana the royal rebel of 20-30
years ago
is a deeply significant event it's a
recognition
of this changing style of the british
monarchy this
common touch this love affair flirting
with the media
is now mainstream for the royal family
now here's what we know about dianette's
60s that she would have been the
grandmother
to five small children but when we
consider the tensions between her sons
tensions in a way we've never seen
before since prince harry decided to
step back from royal duties
what we do have to remember is that in
her life princess diana
made the very same decision anthony he
has tayyip at kensington palace thank
you i
i still can't even when they said diana
is 60 i was like
two i was just the grandmother of five
it's hard to believe it's been you know
25 years since we lost her
that's right i just i couldn't even i
couldn't even come i couldn't process it
yeah it should be a beautiful tribute to
her today yeah